>> Keith: HE'S SMART ENOUGH TO
KNOW HE'MAYBE
HIGHER.
FLORIDA LOOKS TOUGH TO CATCH AT
THIS POINT. E'LL GO BACK TO GET
IT AS BOTH TEAMS MAKE ANGS ON, R
H
SPEED IS CONNECT  THE.CK.
LINDBLOM, THREE LEAFS AROUND
HIM. WHO WAS IN
THE PAST WITH NEW YORK.
PROGRAM TO HAYES, HE SCORES!
AND
BACK OUT IT GOES TO RIELLY.
MATTHEWS I I
IT'S OUT OF THE REACH AND
RI
HALL BACK TOMOVE.
THE PUCK SLID OFF HIS STICK BUT
>> Keith:
LEAFS HEREWEN WHO ACROSS TO RIE
RIELLY SHARP, SAVE MADE THE PASS
DOWN HE SCORES!
WHO SKATES UP THE ICE, HEAD UP
ALL THE WAY.
HE'S THINKING  -- FIVE
A SIDE HOCKEY WITH 7:42 TO
THIS ONE, IT SEEMED LIKE THIS
GAME WAS GOING TO SLIP AWAY.
LIKE BUNTING GOT A TIP ON THAT.
HART IN DESPERATION, TRIED TO
GET PUCK INSTEAD OF
NYLANDER AT THE PHILADELPHIA
LINE, INTO THE MIDDLE, A SHOT
AND HE SCORES!
HIS
FOREHAND AND SLIDES IT INTO A